thank you uh yes sir i'm here with
mvl after quite a difficult game but
very very interesting and uh filled with
content
tell us uh maxime how did the opening go
for you
it seemed like you prepared this move 10
rook to b1 was it uh
or sorry rotates b7 14 tell us a little
bit about that
yeah i mean there's not much to tell
it's not the most uh
critical line obviously but uh yeah
i thought it was worth a try and uh but
yeah i mean after bishop c5 i felt
already that um
yeah it's not really great because if i
go book c6
take take bishop d7 in fx7 look
to c8 and i might
already not be doing great and something
like this is also
like i mean i was not sure and it's
needed for
for him but uh like e6 would lose to
grenada
how much risk were you willing to take
uh in this game
well not this is the point of losing by
four spaces absolutely yeah this one
seems pretty bad for you
yeah already and you decided to go uh at
this point
actually after um bishop to c8 or
b6 castle did you consider rook to f3
yeah did you have this in your
preparation at all yeah uh of course
focusing was a move but
um yeah i didn't think it's like
uh so great so
but yeah like of course it's
probably more venomous than the game i'm
not really sure but
yeah i i mean i almost got something
which is
uh crazy because it's um actually close
for me but um the sad thing is
like of course this was a little trick i
have
okay and you cannot play bishop d5
because of knight b5
and what if you take well you cannot
release like this
it should be three yeah this is probably
lost already
this is lost well just because the king
goes in
dark squares i mean compared to the game
i have the c pawn so my knight is
much more very interesting yeah yeah so
how would you be able to get
rid of this king if i put it on e7 for
example so let's say like this this
yeah i just put my king to v7
yeah i'm not really sure i can go first
king c5
um let's say i look in ec6
okay let's say okay let's say i do this
because i want to do it
yeah let's say
not really completely sure as i should
do g4 g5 but let's say
and at some point you're going to give a
check king d6 and then slowly slowly
you're going to push me
it's not completely clear yet or why it
should win actually but
uh i assumed this would give great
winning chances at least
absolutely also after okay 2 i'm not
even forced to take on a6 i can
first play something like g4 because
bishop b5 isn't still not possible
bishop d7 still fails to k7 although k4
might
be close to holding i don't know and
even if he manages to transfer
rook here then the bishop is going to be
defending yeah
but yeah but rx4 was a good move because
now king distribution b5
and i considered this so let's say okay
four first
and oh yeah king c3 i assumed it's gonna
be a
an easy draw for him like even
buying something maybe i'm wrong a3
here just right
well it's better too yeah but it's
better to bring the king because that
makes sense that makes sense
yeah yeah but after rookie [ __ ] this
i mean i assume this
would be a draw maybe i'm wrong because
rocky 5 seems to be
it seems like probably once he gets the
king to the c file you can just go king
three or king a2 and uh yeah this looks
windy almost
yeah no it's it was clearly a try
uh maybe it's better than to bring the
king first to the party
because no yeah this this is much better
version
because you don't have a5 because of d4
and after king this i can go
either hook e1
or d4 right away yeah but yeah
it was maybe a better practical chance
from what i did because i thought i
might have some chances here but
um yeah i mean constantine just see it
and they can just sit you cannot take
the point of v6
never move the knight away and uh yeah
well
uh how do you feel about this result i
know it's probably not necessarily what
you were
striving for but what is the strategy
going into the next few games
yeah well i mean i think i am more or
less recovered physically
from my little illness or whatever
that was uh so i'm glad already not to
be playing with the mask and
to to be like slowly getting back to
full shape
and yeah i definitely hope to
to be able to to strike at some point
because of course
yeah problem is of course i had uh
my two whites against the two uh were
straight hit
uh players but uh they're doing great so
far so
you know it doesn't mean anything maybe
a lot of uh i mean i'm hoping to have
some chances
later on awesome thank you very much max
team and good luck in the rest of your
games thank you
guys back to you